according to the available data
new york has vaccinated more
out-of-towners
than minorities who actually live here
in new york
i mean they need to beef up the
screening process you know like before
giving someone a shot
just ask them to walk six feet on a
sidewalk and then if they stop and look
up at a building to admire it you send
their ass back to connecticut
we should mention that the daily show i
just love him is on comedy central it's
a division of
by the way viacom cbs so we are so
excited to be joined there he is for the
host for the music's biggest night
trevor noah trevor let me just say
anthony tony and i are all here together
we want to know
how can we help you
you help yes as you make your debut as a
grammy host
what can we do to help you trevor nella
that's why we're here
uh wow you know what gail nobody has
asked me that question i
i've actually taken a backfire i'm
always being asked to help people
how can you help i think on the day on
the day if you could come i'll make
space for you because there's going to
be tons of space
so i'll have three chairs for gail and
the tonys that's my band name for you
guys
and then you guys are just going to sit
in like a vip seat all the time and then
you guys just you laugh at the jokes you
applaud you
because you'll be the live one we can do
that we'll cheer you on trevor what i
think is so cool
you've called the grammys trevor's
biggest night
so how are you feeling how are you
getting ready for this wow
how am i feeling i'm i'm all the
feelings i'm nervous
i'm terrified i'm excited i'm ecstatic
i'm
yeah because think about it first of all
it's my first time hosting the grammys
second of all it's my first time hosting
the grammys during a pandemic uh
third of all it's my first time doing
anything like
like like in a year you realize march
14th is going to be the one year
anniversary
of the lockdown like so for me it's just
like yeah one year ago
i remember telling people that i worked
with i was like all right guys three
weeks
we stay at home and then we're all back
yeah and now here we are
a year later three weeks so i i yeah
it's gonna be like do you fit into a
suit
you know how do you look in a suit i
don't know so we're all in the middle of
pandemic productions what do the grammys
look like in pandemic productions
well you know what that's why i got to
credit the team um that's that's putting
it together what's really amazing
is they figured out a way to make an
award show
for the time as opposed to like trying
to like crowbar and award show
into like like it's not it's not zoom
it's not pandemic
it's performances live in los angeles
they've got like multiple stages it's a
really cool setup where
like the bands are sort of going to be
performing for each other
and then for the tv audience so you know
in normal years
there's a live audience and then the
band performs to them and then you sit
at home and you're like yeah
whereas now it's like no it's for you at
home it's it's specifically designed for
that so
i'm excited because they've done a
really amazing job and
there are a few surprises a few treats
that i can't tell you about
but i will tell you this if you see the
music yes yes
you can you can tell us go ahead i can't
i can't see these are surprises but it's
not a surprise well let's talk about the
nominations then trevor uh we've got
beyonce
leading uh the nominations top nominated
artist nine nominations and then six
apiece for taylor swift uh dua lipa
and uh roddy rich and gayle is so happy
that i was able to say do alipa's name
correctly i have young children
i have young children so sometimes i
struggle uh of those
top nominated artists which song among
them
do you most enjoy singing along to i
think i might sing do aleppo the most
just because that's the song i sing
most of the time in the shower don't
stop now that's like me
just to get me going you can't listen to
her music it's so true trevor you can't
listen to her music without getting out
of your seat but
are the actual artists going to be there
can you say because i know you said it's
all out yes
people are going to be there accepting
awards the people it's i promise you
it's like nothing you've ever seen which
is which is why i was so excited to do
it because when i got the call
they were like hey trevor do you want to
do the grammys then i was like at my
house
i do everything at my house i'm tired of
at my house
i don't want to do it at my house and
they're like no we're actually doing the
grammys i was like i'm in
have you offered have you offered the
song stylings of trevor noah
to the grammy folks because we know does
he have song styles we know you've said
before we have we have proof that you've
sung on the last time
you were before the live studio audio
and i think we have video of this
time for social distancing
pack your things and go
just know that i'll be waiting that's
great
so will you be singing give a shout out
to the haters that was my uh that was my
debut
and my retirement of uh it was a song i
sang to the audience our final show
of having a live audience when the when
the pandemic was shutting down
everything
to answer your question no the grammys
have not asked me to sing
but they've said it's because they they
have this thing where they don't like
the artists on the night to
feel overshadowed by like just extreme
and amazing performances
and so that's so generous of you trevor
it's yeah i
can't do all of it hosting and being the
best performer on the night that
i mean that's it's too much trevor noah
you were the perfect
perfect perfect person to do it this
year you and ben winston the producer
thank you
that's a great combo i i like that
cheering you on always thank you you can
see the daily social distancing show
weeknights on comedy central did we
mention
it's a division of viacom cbs is it yes
it is
and watch trevor noah host the 63rd
annual grammy awards on sunday march
14th
eight eastern five pacific right here on
cbs a division of viacom cbs